if you want sneaky cardio 90 minutes of
singles is a thousand calories you're
not doing cardio you're chasing a ball a
thousand calories on a concept 2 skio
miserable idea of hell so people who are
most disciplined aren't actually more
disciplined they figure out something to
do in the meantime so it's like you did
the same cardio as a guy on the skier he
gets off he's like I'm so
disciplined and to you it didn't feel
like discipline I felt like the opposite
hashtag find your pickleball find your
pickleball and then get puffy on it stop
trying to make puffy a thing puppy's not
going to be a thing oh it's going to be
huge big puff I don't know whether it's
the same in America but puff means
something different in England so Puff
Daddy meant something very different for
you guys Puff Daddy meant something
incredibly different to us yeah sugar
pups also different